es handelt sich um die energiereichsten
naturphänomene der erde die rede ist von
terrestrischen gammablitze ein
instrument installiert an der außenseite
der internationalen raumstation iss
ermöglicht jetzt neue super spektakuläre
erkenntnisse zu diesem geheimnisvollen
und bisher kaum erforschten strahlungs
blitzen unter anderem auch zu den
mysteriösen elfen leuchterscheinungen
klicks zu science fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen das gerät
auf dem große hoffnung ruht heißt asien
das steht für at mosphere space in der
actions monitor installiert ist es an
der außenseite der internationalen
raumstation iss und mit seiner hilfe
werden seit sommer 2008 zehn gewitter
weltweit genauer ins visier genommen
dazu der norwegische weltraum
wissenschaftler nikola ist gar der dass
asien projekt leitet das besondere dabei
ist dass wir erstmals nach sichtbaren
licht und nacht gammastrahlung zugleich
suchen können das eröffnet und komplett
neue möglichkeiten konkret verfügt das
at mosphere space interactions monitor
asien der europäischen weltraumagentur
esa über eine vielzahl an instrumenten
mit dabei unter anderem zwei
röntgendetektor in zwei kammern die
lektoren 3v detektoren zwei licht messer
mit optischer wellenlänge und zwei
hochgeschwindigkeits kameras kaum
vorstellbar aber tatsächlich tappten
forschungsteams weltweit zu den
konkreten abläufen bei terrestrischen
gamma blitzen im dunkeln
für uns auf der erde ist es
nachvollziehbar dass sturm donner und
blitz per se ein dramatisches
naturschauspiel sind doch bei einem
gewitter spielen sich hoch oben in den
wolken prozesse ab die für uns
eigentlich unsichtbar sind das können
auch piloten und pilotinnen bezeugen die
bei ihren flügen mysteriöse
leuchterscheinungen beobachten die
manchmal auch als elfen und kobolde
bezeichnet werden der große vorteil des
asien projektes hierbei können blitze
aus dem weltall beobachtet werden und
genau das liefert spektakuläre
erkenntnisse insgesamt zählte das gerät
in den zehn monaten 217 terrestrische
gammablitze die sich in einer höhe von
10 bis 15 kilometern abspielten
jedes ereignis dauerte etwa 1 10
tausendstel einer sekunde bei blitzen
die innerhalb einer wolke von unten nach
oben laufen entsteht den neuen
erkenntnissen zufolge die strahlung ein
weiteres super spannendes ergebnis
welches das norwegische forschungsteam
durch asien erfahren dürfte dem
sichtbaren blitz gibt ein gamma puls
voraus der entsteht dadurch dass
elektronen auf luftmoleküle prallen
diese werden angeregt so dass die
strahlung abgeben um quasi wieder zur
ruhe zu kommen
diese erkenntnis ist sowohl war die
frage der reihenfolge unbeantwortet
geblieben aber auch ein dänisches
forschungsteam befasste sich genauer mit
den messungen von asien hier wurden vor
allem blitze an der tunesischen insel
sulawesi ins visier genommen besonders
spannend war hierbei ein atmosphärischer
gammastrahlen witz der nur einige
millionstel sekunden dauerte und über
einem gewitter am 10 10 2010 an bord der
iss gemessen werden konnte die fachleute
bekamen dadurch nämlich spannende
erkenntnisse zu den phänomenen die schon
oft vom pilotinnen und piloten
beobachtet wurden die rede ist von
mysteriösen leuchterscheinungen mit dem
namen elfen chats oder kobolde zum einen
die jets dabei handelt sich um
leuchterscheinungen die als blaue blitze
wahrgenommen wurden
sie schießen direkt aus der
gewitterwolke nach oben
anders die rötlichen kobolde die als
schwache licht emissionen beobachtet
werden und direkt über einem gewitter
schlagartig in die höhe schießen
doch spätestens jetzt ist klar dass das
mit physik zu erklären ist und es sich
keineswegs um aberglauben handelt das
dänische forschungsteam kam durch ihre
studie zu der erkenntnis dass das elfen
leuchten also eine andere entscheidung
dass eine ultraviolette
leuchterscheinung meint mit gewitter
zusammen hängt es entsteht wenn auch
kurze gammastrahlenblitze bei gewitter
entstehen konkret wurde es in der oberen
schicht der erdatmosphäre also der
ionosphäre registriert doch wie hängt
der gewitterblitz mit dem ultravioletten
leuchten zusammen beim aufflackern eines
gewitterblitz es entsteht ein
elektromagnetisches feld so dass in der
umgebung elektronen beschleunigt werden
wenn diese mit anderen luftteilchen
wechselwirken weil sie extrem schnell
unterwegs sind kann dadurch gamma
strahlung entstehen das ergebnis hierbei
ein atmosphärischer gamma blitz der nur
30 bis 49 millionstel sekunden an
doch nicht nur das der gewitterblitz hat
außerdem starke elektromagnetische
wellen zur folge die sich in die oberen
atmosphärenschichten ausbreiten und zwar
in form eines elektromagnetischen pulses
emp der am unteren rand der ionosphäre
energie auf elektronen überträgt diese
kollidieren dann mit glas molekülen in
der atmosphäre und genauso erklärt das
team in der aktuellen studie das meist
ultraviolette leuchten mit dem namen
elfen es breitet sich dann aus wie die
wellen auf der oberfläche eines sees ein
total verrückter anblick in denen man
einen stein geworfen hat ihre erklärung
sehen die fachleute auch durch ihre
beobachtung bestätigt dass das elfte
leuchten nahezu zeitgleich mit dem gamma
blitz auftrag mega explosionen im
weltraum gamma ray burst da geht es bei
astro also hier anklicken unbedingt da
gibt es bei astro comics tv um
gammablitze im weltraum also anklicken
anschauen super spannendes thema und
unbedingt us comics tv abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran